shook never hung anybody over the
balcony so vanilla ice never got hung
over the bottom okay definitely got hung
over the balcony
but see it's kind of like the kid that
got kicked
and all the teachers seen was a kid
doing the hitting right what people
don't talk about is that little young
black kid right who did the production
for ice ice baby
who vanilla ice said [ __ ] you i'm not
gonna give you four or five million
dollars people don't want to talk about
he
went through every resource he could to
get his money
and the [ __ ] wasn't right when he
brought it to suge knight she said sug
i'll give you half the money you can get
my money sugar said young black brother
i don't want half your money i just want
what's reasonably coming to me let me
have my attorneys contact them and
figure it out after eight and nine
months of that not working then he went
through other extremes of getting it
done now watch this
is it
suge knight's fault that he had to go to
that extreme or is it vanilla ice's
fault for totally ignoring it when it
was trying to be handled the corporate
way fair enough
so i you know i just got to defend that
because i know what's really behind that
it wasn't a thing with sure came in and
i ain't want no [ __ ] verse for
vanilla
the [ __ ] you know what i'm saying and
let the record be shown and do not [ __ ]
with whack either you know what i'm
saying because i've seen the dark side
of whack as well personally me myself